よし
こんにちははじめた超で子役の時からずっと見てたんだけど
神木隆之介機神ティルの助っ人奴が何か他に youtube やり始めたらしくて
なんだけ
ユーチューブ youtube っていう名前でなんか youtube やり始めた
んだけどねえっつっいるらしいですよ
神木隆之介がいるらしいんで芸能
ロングべきから言うとたぶんルーの好きの方が上だと思うんだけども youtube
で光る言うと俺の観点上大先輩
きょうは完全に上期にマウントとってめちゃくちゃ youtube のことを教えて
いきつつ
g の雲海のこともちょっとねえつから教えてもらえたら一番いい
いいかなとか思いつつなんかもううちの事務所の前まで来て
ぽいんでちょっと今日はあの俺叩き込んでよるとも youtube という世界の強
さを行こう
[拍手]
さあ来いカメリーノて来い来い御膳恋
ブーバーン舌からでもういいよああああぬーんっ
はい
キター
続けてますねー
ああよろしくお願い宜しくお願いします
すごいんですよろしくお願いしまーす
ブーブー末期ほんともう初対面でございますっ
吉新てぃです
面接をですよろしくお願いますよ
んとっ
見てますねめっちゃ細いの政府ですが上期くん
[音楽]
ブーブー一生 asa us are you do
くださいワイドスナップ
そうだね今日は継母いや目4ご利益やめろやんだよ
豊城で
世の中の誰が神くんと
始めたその合っていると思っているでしょうか突然なんですけど絶対外かみっくんはい
どもテレビつければもうね質問コーナーみたいなやつけどやってるんですよぉー
金泥突然 twitter で募集してると思いますよ
映像いうやつですか
上期部長それは続く作業江波南
専用よしズレみましたもうやばい冊3冊ほど髪切る増で
[音楽]
すごい早くぞえっものの1両で219位いい音ズレねすごいイエスとなった
お互いの印象はお互いの意思はもう
クラスの人気者でか
me
そういう時もあった surface 時もアダンか中学校の時を生徒会副会長をも
高校バスケ部の部長盤質なんだけど
授業中は静かあっあーっ地下ちゃしてるから十
結構じゃあ盛り上げて部長と顔して立ったいっ
サイトも本当にあもうふざけ無しで普通に区長として
人真面目に試合に勝つにーく
コーラに月頑張ってだいたい風
何に愛を持って起動みたいなぁそういう音豆腐がすごいタイプです
ハァハァもに君の印象は
いい子
何こっテーズがすごいいいか a 3食ちゃんと食べてますみたいなん
ユーサーシュトルム度でない朝ごはんはパンがですかご飯派ですか
制覇でございました精霊のごはんいらっしゃい
お互いの好きなアニメを教えてくださいを
結構アニメ見る結構アニメ見るこれは
かけグリッティあねー早いあの子を駆け引きみたいな心理戦早
web デスノートがすごく好きんだったからちょっとなんかの中で人生を賭けたンっ
ていうのだ
ん大勝負のう
ゲームない駆け引きがすごいいてるとまでいかないけどなんか通ずるものがそこかうん
んでそれもすごい
ゲー
ちゃんと疑い何を背負って戦ってるかっていうのが描かれてるから
ならそういう素敵だなぁと思い開設前社長はめちゃくす見るんだけど
トータルでいくと
クラナドって言うな立ってみたいクラナドは人生
は身体人生あんですよ
rain a のアニメとか家族のお話といいんだけどすべて含まれてるって言うか
おじいちゃんと顔となるのかなぁを打つの数ね総合的に見て家族関係とか買っとくか
買う人生のいろんな人にフォーカスされるっ
まさに clannad は人生という言葉がそれだっていう
あとは一期は見れたべき見てない日までも生きば2期からが
やそうあっ癖になるはず名も知ったきっかけは何ですかああああしかなくきっかけの
動画とかよくあるっていう10
かけ動画ああっ
ウッドのがでかいドライアイスあえるねくらい俺コレ
あっ操作だぞそう捉えず発揮を
なつかすぃザキドライアイス100機分あって我々は見たことがあります
確かにドライスって売っちゃってなかったらどうなるんだろう何が起きるんだろうか
まったく予想がつかない
自分たちのプラーナ夢をすべて変えてくれたらしたな
黒猫し大暴露を踏み聞く
運河くるべきじゃは何かあっありますえっと学生生活の時に高校の時にモテたくであ
くーらー人間がモテるんだろうなと思って1日だけ
つまり全くしゃべれないなぁちょっと塩対応したければゆめ2位のやつかな
その時に女子から具合悪いよ的に打っにょ
クラリー8脚やばいるんだけど黒でき記そう
病だもん生きる黒リク死んでるのがあるから中学校の時に
携帯
買ってくれなくて高校までだからモックってわかる
に専門のも消えたりあああああのボタン日本品みたいだけどそれをカッコつけてもっぱ
じゃあ故障で扱ってくる face てくれっ子よりしまいじゃこりゃーっ
広がっいつも家で何ソレコレ
だみたいなんですが1校朝起きて絶対に指に入る
そうなんだイベでに入ってさ
ゲーム+本来エルフ
zune 分で外でなきゃってキンタロー危機感を感じ絶対に外に1回やってる皆さん
もまずまずか追い込み大丈夫ので俺は
[音楽]
ブーブーこれはちょっと俺聞いたら結婚あーありますかぁーヌーけどちっはこれ
どういう危機感があるかっていうと結婚しなきゃいけないけどすごい期間じゃなくて
覚悟を背負わなきゃいけないと知らんのかな
結婚って人と生活して人も腕を人生と共にいく作業ですからそれでば株は必要です世
議員と
やるからにはねやっぱり au 一生背負わなきゃいけないかそういう例えばないか
結構じゃなくと思う
きゅっきゅ弾をできるソープレッツ責任を覆われ1ないパール re やばいああああ
ヌードっ
いっ
見るなーすごいソンヌ俺は
すき家伸ばしたいですああこれはいいいつもなぁ芸能界入っていなければ何をしてまし
たか
まあ
機会にの辞典第二の人生まあ
知事をどっかの企業には勤めていたうん
けど部署は絶対に開発課営業
まあ bao こそせた営業に行きたいよろしくねますすごい評価高くてながら今でも
どっかでいいよっている
上期くんのあの売上のやつだけ高くなってそうでアートものおりだよなっ
なっていたかった2分塾の先生
教育学部でない
じゃあもう全然先生っていうもスムーズ勉強をせた気がします
すごい便化後2つのそうなみたいな浪人生なのですがメンタルが弱くて冗長保つ秘訣を
教えてください
地方庁保つ
冗長と持つ
コッツ秘訣
駅本庄町は不安定上を行く
いい
だと桜 a 案で安定なしてると思うけど
ずっと安定してみたいない夏がいる普通にこれも落ち込むしもう本当にずっとこの噴火
ていくでしょう
あるけど不安なわけですね
1年みんなと遅れつあるわけだから
孤独感が凄そうな気がするのは確かに友達たちとか
同じ学年に入りたかったっていう思いもあるだろう美味しい早く入りたい早くやりたい
ことをやりたい
っていうあるけど最終目的としてはその学校に行くことが出ねぇ何を待って
その先ほどスマーなるべく早く入りたいのもちろん生んだけどよそが焦ってを多分
細かいミス
上手くなっておくするしその問題もそうだしそっち曲選択ございます
だとすると
焦らずにゆっくりとまず確実に入る
そっちでやっていいけばいいまあ入れなかったとしてもは猿ってそこで終わりじゃない
からそのさっき屋根急いでやることじゃない
そういう人生きてなった
意外とお住まいなら自分で他に好きなことを言っねうん売れちゃうかもしれない
実は
今までこれこれ入っててこれと違うこと取ってやってたら大学費払っちゃうよ占める
大体がつかないことになる牛っていう風になるかもしれないって言ってず焦らず目標が
あるが確実にまずそこに到達することだけを考えれば
フロアせる筆は者がかけ自分が納得いくようにやってくだ
これからはきたことで気合で頑張れ2人の身長差は
で結構ある意気なん16720センチ勝ち額を知る
却下時から180ですバッハぜんぜんってねめちゃくちゃ暮らしてもらおう
8好きな色は何ですか普段僕は x live 使ってる君のに色のイメージが強い
ドローン実が開かれますけどあと
ねー赤黒が好きでこうゆうぴょん
なぁあんたクラッいくロボットあーよテンションあっ
そりゃあかっこいいパパか俺はオレンジ
i am お母さんが持っ薄ピンクモスきた住んでるそうだからこれ自分チェスんです
けど全部作ったあっ本当の道部基準てる次郎ドレッジ
れ死後言うんか
ハワイアンだねいいのが言っても一番この顔が漏れるだって胸像ファンに向けてお願い
します
おっいやのトニック受けろ
せーの
ありがとうございますと言いスマイル0特にないです
俺も聞いてみたりしてもいけません生きている上での自分が大切にしている信念みたい
なを聞きたいな
を
ぜひ一つありますそうそれは
自分が楽しいと思えるかとうーん
はすごい大事だなとあ
自分もそうだし楽しんでくれれば混ぜになって一番先生
持っ
続けることもあるわけだからそれは
[音楽]
楽しいって応援いただければ続けられないんどう
自分の役者っていう仕事も今のところ楽しいってもやってるん辛いことがあっても
楽しいって覚えているからこうやって今れ
を白い歯にしてるのかなと
社長
[音楽]
得にない
定款レストも募集させていただきましたやっぱりレーサーそうみんな最善のことになっ
て好きで
神木隆之介くんと初めてお会いしたんですけどもどうでした a やボートファンだっ
たんで嫌や骨を売りする
僕もなんか小さいころからテレビで活躍されているかだとこうやって話せるのが本当に
良い
奥貫ですのことを泣かせくださいジャンですね紙一君のチャンネル流通部もありますの
で
概要欄から是非チェックして3年登録してみてください
はいそして神くんの際年の方でも連れ出して頂いておりますのでぜひチェックしてみて
ください
そのがちょっとあの社長の方が早く手袋もちょっと遅いかもしれないですけど
あとカーズ
boku channel でも社長でていただいているので
いたしますというわけで以上始めるぞ上期不条理さ
ズー
[音楽]
うぉっは